chuckle I have had a few rough months
some setbacks at work that hurt me
financially which is stressed out my
family I'm late on some payments I'm
falling further behind at work I don't
want to tap out but I just don't know
where to start well you know what that's
that's just kind of the way that life
works sometimes it's it's Murphy's Law
when things go wrong they always seem to
happen at once and they just compound on
top of each other and it's it's pretty
easy sometimes to to feel beaten when
you're faced with all those issues and
all those problems and they all hit you
at the same time but let me tell you
that that doesn't mean give up in fact
it means the opposite it means it's time
for you to fight harder to dig in means
it's time for you to go on the warpath
and that starts with one of the
fundamental laws of combat leadership
prioritize and execute what's the
biggest problem what's causing the most
stress family okay sit them down explain
where you are at be blunt be upfront and
then give them the simple plan of how
you're going to get things back on track
don't sugarcoat it you give it to them
straight next
got some some late payments call those
creditors up explain to them what's
going on set up some kind of a minimum
payment plan so you can start making
some progress and get them off your back
and then you got your job right you're
falling behind at work okay talk to your
boss
face it tell him that you're going to
step up your game tell him you're going
to be at work early you're gonna be at
work late you're going to be at work
during lunch you're going to be wherever
you need to be whenever he needs you to
be there
tell him you're gonna get after it and
tell that you're a hundred percent
committed to supporting him and the
company and the mission and then you get
started and I'm going to tell you right
now it won't be easy it will be hard
because life is hard that's what life is
and these challenges these challenges
that you face they're gonna do their
best to take you down do not let them
stand up dig in line up those problems
and confront them face them fight them
do not let them bring you down in fact
in fact let those challenges raise you
up let them elevate you let their
demands and their trials make you
stronger
let the adversity you face today turn
you into a better person tomorrow
so so in the future you look back at
these struggles and you say to them
thank you you made me better